ازيكم السفر حلم الشباب كتير مين هنا
فقع طيب مين يعرف سفر بالفعل
اوفر خلص هو حل كل شاب
مصر كل شاب مصر بفكر امتى يجي الوقت اللي
يقدر يصير ال بيسافر وبشوف معذور في حاجه
زي كده لانه من كتر الظروف اللي بتحصل
حوالينا بيكون موط ومتوتر ومدايق ومش قادر
خلاص حاس
البلد و تستغربوش لما تعرفوا ان
53%
بنسبه سواء كان هجره شرعيه وغير شرعيه هم
من الشباب من الشباب من سن 25 سنه 34
سنه انا كنت واحد من الشباب ده كنت
بفكر بسع اسال نفس
سؤال هل ده الحل هل الحل ان احنا نسيب
البلد لغايه ما تصوره 25
يناير الثوره اديتني فرصه افكر هو احنا
منين بنعمل ايه وخليتني اكتشف روعه الشعب
المصري لما نزلنا في البان التحرير وكنا
بنشوف ولد بيحمي ص اصل بكاف على الصيحي
اللي كان بيحاول يكرب او بيحاول يدمر كان
بيتقال له سلميه
سلميه اكتشفنا شعب تاني اكتشفنا نفسنا
وجاي احساس ان احنا لبسنا نظاره جديده
وبدانا نشوف بيها بعض وبدنا نتعامل بيها
مع بعض طب حاله ايجابيه غير مصوه
كان احساس بالفخر لاي حد كان ناشي في
البدايه حسينا ان مصر تاني رجعت لنا وان
احنا خلاص هنبقى واحده من الدول المتقدمه
وناس كتير وانتم عارفينهم غيروا تفكير
مع ومن كتر حماس الشباب وفرحته باللي بلده
فيه فكر يعمل ايه فقرر ان هو يم
الاص شباب عنده طاقه عنده باور عاوز يعمل
حاجه للبلد يعمل ايه
تفكير بس غالبا كانت طاه حماسته اوتر الان
اللي معاه بداد اي حد يعني في ناس بتن على
نص على الاشجار على اي
حاجه الشباب ده عن عظماء وزعماء العالم
كلام اجاري كتير جدا لدرجه ان الس لاول
مره في التاريخ نرى شعبا يقوم بثوره وماص
الشوارع بعدها مين دولول
احنا
الشباب حاس خلاص ان مصر رجعتله ومجرد
ماشال نظام كنا فاكرين ان هو عاوز نفضل
كده احنا
خلاص لكن يا فرحه
مات احداث كتير حصلت وم لقيناش مصر اللي
احنا عاوزينها الموضوع اختلف مش دي مصر
اللي احنا كنا مخها ورجعنا تاني قلعنا
النظاره السليمه اللي كنا لابسينها ولبسنا
النظاره المنصوره اللي عشنا بها طول
حياتنا وال سبب
في اللي احنا فيه
حالنا لبسنا اضار وانا مالي ودي الكلمه
الشهيره اللي كلنا او اغلب بستم وانا مالي
دي ماليش علاقه بيها وانا مالي المشكله دي
حصلت وانا مالي اهم حاجه ان انا مش عندي
اهم حاجه انا ما مضرنيش انا شخصيا وده
بشوف ان وانا ماال مشكله او جزء من اهم
مشكله ب المص دوقت حاجه زي التحرش هي بد
وان فدخلت نفس كتير قوي بيفكروا تفكير
سلبي خلت ناس كتير قوي تكون ولا ي طالما
ما جتش عندي لبسنا نظاره
معلش معلش في بيت معلش في الشغل معلش معلش
مضوع مبد مهم جدا اللي هو المحاسبه
والمسؤوليه في وسط كلمه معلش ما بقيناش
بنحاسب ما بقيناش بدقق قوي مين عمل ايه
معلش رجعنا نلبس نظاره مافيش
طبعا دي عار جهله او الشماعه اللي بعل
عليها مشاكل كتير واللي سبب وجهه نظري
بارتفاع نسبه البطاله في مصر عشان توصل ل
13% شباب القول مافيش فايده انا اطور نفسي
ليه وانا ليه اكون افضل ليه اكون احسن
ومستني الحكومه توظف والمقوله الشهيره
اللي حضرتكم عارفنها
والفكه هو مستني يري علشان يكون في وضع
مستقر مش محتاج يتطور محدش يقدر يشيه
وبالتالي هو في احسن
حاجه نجيب نظاره التمني
او بنحب نحط الناس اللي بنتم معهم في
قوال انت في اي قب عشان ابدا اتعامل معاه
وبالتالي لو شفنا واحد مرتحي بنقول عليه
بفتكر ان الهاب وده هاب
متطرب لما بشوف واحده مش محدبه بنقول
عليها هي اكيد مش كويسه و و وك قبل ما
اتعامل معاك بحب احطك في ق الاول عشان
اعرف صدر لك اي صوره دهنيه عندي واتعامل
معاك دي نضاره مشوره جدا نظاره
التعصب تعصب في السياسه تعصب في الكوره
تعصب في الشغل وجهه نظري هي اللي صح
والمقوله اللي احنا حبنا ماشي فيها رايي
صواب ولا يحتمل الخطا ورايك اكيد برض مهما
عملت
النظارات دي
خلتنا دي م كتير سبب في الواقع احنا
عايشين
فيه بس اللي فكرت فيه وزعل جدا ان النظرات
دي وتاثيرها يبدا يقرب مني ويبدا يدورني
ويبدا يدور ودي وده اللي يخليني اتحرك قبل
فخر ده يجي
عن تبعنا كلنا وشوفنا حوادث كتير خاصه
اطفال
تحديدا طفل يموت علشان ازاز وقع على افه
ومات اطفال يوا علشان ير المدرسه يقع
عليهم عان حد قال ولا تي وما تعملوش صيانه
بيني وبينكم فكرت لو ولادي هم اللي في
الموقف ده وجعتهم الصبح انا مطهم رايحين
المدرسه مرجعليش
وده حال اسر كتير ودعت ولادها وما يش و
لهم
وتعل دي نتيجه منظرات كتير ناس احنا جزء
من
المشكله ولكن انا متفائل
وفي ليه
متفائل لان ق فتره ادور هي مشكله فين ايه
اللي مخلينا مش عارفين نكون دوله او مجتمع
متحضر زي بنشوفه بره د هحكي لكم تجربه
سريعه رحت يا
قعدت هناك سبع
ايام في السبع
ايام كان عجباني جدا فكره الاك طبعا عشان
المصل ده كان الاختراع بالنسبه تلاقي ان
في مكان مناسب او مكان مخصص لمور المشاه
فعجبني جدا روح المكان بش ا لغايه ما
استمر الشار تفل عربيات تقف دي بيور عادي
عادي متوف جدا وحيه وانا مش كف اي حاجه
رجعت مصر قعدت 48 ساعه كل ما اجي عد
الشارع بدور على فين المكان وجو الشارع
اكيد ماوش والحمد لله ما طولتش في الحال
وخلال يعني 24 ساعه كمان كان الحمد لله
رجعي الحال المصيه الشارع
ازاي التجربه دي خلتني افكر وايه اللي
حصللي في السبعه ايام يعني ايه اللي خلاني
اتعامل زي ما الجارد بيتعلم
واحترم اشاره المرور واحترم ان انا اعدي
من مكان اللي حصل فيه ده اك المشكله مش
فينا كمصريين مش في الجين المصري يعني انا
ما عنديش ينات متخليني بتعامل كده وامثله
تانيه كتير جدا مساد زي دكتور زبد اجل
يعقو هاني عازم الناس دي سيفر بره بجز
المجتمعات دي يبقى اصار سهم فبالتالي احنا
مش ناقصين حاجه الجين المصري الحمد لله
طمط ان هو
سليم طيب هل المشكله ان عددنا كبير كده س
عددنا كبير وعندنا مشكله
اكتشفنا ان لا مش دي
المشكله دوله زي الصين عددها مليار و350
مليون مثلا يعني 15 ض عدد
المصريين وبيشوفوا ان التنوع ده مصهر قو
التنوع ده مش مشكله ض على
حل يبقى المشكله مش في العدد الكبير هل
المشكله ان مافيش فلوس
م عندناش
موارد برض
لا دول كتير ما عندهاش موارد زي
اليابان وهر
تقريبا عندها فلوس وعندها وعندها بس انا
ماهاش عندها اار مط وارهاب وعددهم اقل من
بكتير مشكله في
فلوس هل المشكله في الجول اله
مثلا خلت افكر خينا نفكر مع بعض لو خدنا
الشعب المصري نقلناه
وناه خدنا الشعب الااني نقلناه وجبناها
مصر ايه اللي يحصل مصر وايه اللي
يحصل بالظبط زي ماحق زي ما
تخيلت مصر فيها تكنولوجيا وكشر وفيها
وفيها وفيها امانيا طما فيها مقطوعه ارب
ساعات فيها زاله في الشارع في الناس مش
عارفه يعني الدنيا دايه مش
عارفين ده الوضع ي بالتالي المشكله مش الج
المكله مش في البلد المكله
في طيب ايه المشكله يعني انت عملت مش
بفلوس مش في الد مش في الجو ايه
المشكله في عالم اسمه مبي دي مقوله شهيره
جدا بقول ان الانسان يعيش في لاث اعوام
عالم الافكار
عالم الاشخاص عالم
الاشياء زي الهرم
قم ده الهرم هو عالم الاخلاص دي انماط
التفكير ومنظومه الافكار اللي احنا بنفكر
بفكر ب اي مجتمع مشاعر واحاسيس بتحركنا
بشكل
عا تاني ع الاشخاص وه الناس اللي بيتحركوا
هو الناس تحرك نتيجه الافكار اللي في
ونتيجه الافكار تنع بيها وتتعامل واخر
عالم هو عالم الاشياء وده الناتج المادي
النموس اللي في اخر اللي بينتج عن الاشخاص
دي شكل علمي زراعه صناعه
فن وكلكم عارفين وزي عندنا مشكله في عالم
الافراد عندنا مشكله في عالم الاشخاص
عندنا مشكله في عالم الاشياء خ مثال بسيط
عشان اوصل الصوره فكره
سلبيه زي وانا مي تطلع شخص سلبي بيقول
وانا ماي بتنتج عنها مشكله زي مشكله
الحار عايز تحكم على اي شخص او على اي
مجتمع احكم عليه بثلاث ع عشان تعرف دلوقت
قد ايه متقدم قد ايه متقدم وفين المشكله
اللي
عن عددي الافطار هو النظاره اللي لبسناها
18 يوم وشوفنا بعض بشكل ايجابي وتعاملنا
مع بعض بشكل ايجابي على الافكار هو المطره
المقصوره اللي حكينا عنها من شويه عن
الافكار هو سبب تقدم المجتمعات اليه اللي
احنا بنبص عليها وقول يا ريت مصر تبقى
زيهم تبقى
مز المجتمعات الغربيه مهتمه جدا انها تصلح
النظاره بتاعتها ومهتمه جدا ان النظاره
بتاعتها تكون مش مقصوره علشان يعرفوا
يتعايشوا وينتج
ويفكر دوله
الص الفره الاقتصاديه حصلت فيها كلمه السر
فيها كانت اهتمامهم
بالتعليم التعليم هو تثبيط على الافض مش
اكتر من
كده مهتمين بالاطفال اللي في المدارس
مهتمين بتعليمهم بنظام التعليم لان دول لو
ظبطوا على اهم دول هيب مستد اللي هيب عشان
كده ما تستغربش لما نلاقي ان 18% من
ميزانيه البرازيل موجهه لتعليم وتطوير
العمليه
تعليميه
الصين لابسين نظار التنوع وحاسين وفاهمين
ان ده قوه مش ضعف ولا مشكله عندهم ست
ديانات مختلفه عندهم 56 عرق مختلف
ومعندهمش مشاكل انهم فاهمين يعني ايه
التنوع في بريطانيا ناسين كويس جدا ض
المسؤوليه
وال وزيره الثقافه قدت السابت لما تم
اتهامها بعدد سدات 4500 جنيه سرديني عن
عظومه كانت عاملاها البعض ما دفعتها
واتهموها ان هي ما دفعتها تحتد سالتها
انطلاقا من احساسها بالمسؤوليه وزير الق
البريطاني اكتشفوا بعد فتره انه ما يسدد
فاتوره او مخالفه مرور كتعليم من حوالي 10
سنين و وقدم استقالته لعدم سداده لفق
او ده معناه ايه ده معناه الناسه ناره
المسؤوليه
والمحاسبه
هنا روته ضاعت ست
مرات تخيل روتك ست مرات وكل مره بتشتغل
وتجتهد علشان تعملها من جديد
ده لابس ناره
مبره مش لابس نداره مافيش فايده
اللي احنا يعني مشهورين
بض تخيلوا معايا نص لو لبسنا نظار
النظارات اللي كان عليه شويه نظاره
المسؤوليه نظاره التنوع نظاره الاجتهاد
ممكن تبقى عامله
ازاي انا عندي معادله بسيطه على الافكار
سلم بيطلع انسان
ايجابي الانسان الايجابي بيطلع مجتمع
ايجابي المجتمع الايجابي هو المجتمع
المتحضر فبالتالي على افكار سل بيطلع
مجتمع متحضر وهنا يجي حد يسالني سؤال مهم
جدا اللي انت بتقول ده شيء صحب لان ح
الصدار ايه مافيش فايده وانا باهم الين
على بعض
عمل
خنا اجابه بسيطه جدا دكتور طارس سودان
بيقول عايز تغير مجتمع انت مش مطلوب منك
تغير ير ككل المجتمع مطلوب منك تغير
النسبه
الذهبيه هي 2% من المجتمع لان الباقي
فولورز
الناس لو 2% غيروا عالم اهم وقدموا الدي
المجتمع بتاعهم ال 98% هتبع
2% وعلشان ابقى وقفك جدا ده اللي بيحصل
النهارده فيكس
فيكس جزء من كير على افكار المجتمع المصري
لان هي افكار تستحق
الانتشار حضراتكم جز من
2% قررتوا تيجوا تحض فيكس عشان تسمعوا
حاجه تجروا بيه
حياتكم انا كررت واحد 2% اللي هيغير
المجتمع ده لشيء
افضل وانا على يقين ان حضراتكم جزء
من اللي عايز اقول في النهايه المشكله مش
مشكله فلوس المشكله مش مشكله ععد كبير
المشكله في عالم افطارنا المشكله في
النظاره اللي لابسينها غير ن
شكرا